es ist die zweithäufigste krankheit an
der menschen sterben und jedes jahr gibt
es mehr fälle krems unsere medizin
konnte die pest besiegen und ehemals
tödliche krankheiten wie aids
erfolgreich behandeln trotzdem scheinen
gegen krebs auch nach jahrzehnten noch
immer machen muss zu sein aber die
forschung steht nicht still 1 m rna
impfstoff neue therapien smart drugs und
vieles mehr können uns in zukunft helfen
krebs weniger tödlich zu machen ist dass
die medizinische revolution auf die wir
die ganze zeit gewartet haben und wie
funktionieren diese neuen ansätze
überhaupt genau darum geht es heute
sagte watson
es ist
[Musik]
also erst einmal was ist krebs überhaupt
krebszellen entstehen wenn sich
bestimmte teile unserer erbsubstanz also
unserer gene verändern und diese defekte
nicht mehr repariert werden dabei gilt
je älter der mensch desto
unzuverlässiger arbeitet das
reparatursystem der gene daher liegt das
mittlere erkrankungsalter bei den
meisten krebsarten auch bei 69 jahren
warum der reparaturmechanismus nicht
mehr funktioniert ist jedoch je nach
krebs unterschiedlich
gebärmutterhalskrebs wird zum beispiel
meistens durch bestimmte viren ausgelöst
lungenkrebs entsteht häufig durch
rauchen wieder andere krebsarten sind
erblich bedingt es gilt also krebs ist
nicht gleich krebs und deswegen gibt es
leider auch nicht den einen weg wie alle
krebsarten behandelt werden können und
das stellt die krebsforschung vor enorme
herausforderungen
aber jetzt gab es ja einen durchbruch
oder eine klinische studie für einen
krebsimpfstoff und das ist ziemlich
spannend gleich aus mehreren gründen
erst einmal muss man sagen im gegensatz
zu normalen impfstoffen die eingesetzt
werden bevor man krank wird ist dieser
hier erst interessant wenn man schon
krebs hat denn er muss ganz spezifisch
an den tumor angepasst werden den mann
in seinem körper hat anschließend
funktioniert eher wie ein ganz normaler
m rna impfstoff er zeigt dem immunsystem
wie die defekten zellen krebszellen
aussehen damit der körper sie selber
vernichten kann denn normalerweise kann
der körper das sehr gut mutierte
körperzellen aufspüren und vernichten
sonst hätten wir alle ständig krebs nur
funktioniert das nicht mehr muslime
immunsystem auf die sprünge geholfen
werden und hier steckt schon das erste
große aber denn die gründe warum das
immunsystem den krebs nicht mehr erkennt
sind auch unterschiedlich der impfstoff
kann nur in manchen situationen helfen
und auch nur bei manchen krebsarten
zusätzlich wird es noch viele jahre
dauern bis der impfstoff zugelassen wird
und auch das nur wenn alle klinischen
phasen erfolgreich verlaufen und selbst
dann wird er wahrscheinlich eher als
zusätzliche behandlung neben einer
chemotherapie eingesetzt und ist kein
allheilmittel
ihr seht schon es ist schwierig krebs zu
behandeln deutlicher wird das problem
wenn man sich die bereits existierenden
therapien anschaut chemotherapie
operationen und strahlentherapie
chemotherapien stören den teils prozess
von zellen dh der tumor kann nicht mehr
wachsen die chemotherapie greift alle
krebszellen im körper an super aber der
nachteil ist dass sie auch die gesunden
zellen angreift was zu starken
nebenwirkungen führt hier versucht die
forschung aktuell stoffe zu entwickeln
die gezielt nur die krebszellen
schädigen operationen hingegen entfernen
nur die bereits entdeckten tumore und
auch das nur wenn diese operierbar sind
bei der strahlentherapie wird wiederum
versucht den krebs mit ionisierender
strahlung zu schädigen auch hier werden
gesunde zellen in mitleidenschaft
gezogen dennoch kann diese therapie bei
einigen krebsarten sehr erfolgreich sein
oder zumindest unterstützend wirken und
auch hier arbeitet die forschung daran
immer gezielter nur die krebszellen zu
bestrahlen so richtig ideal sind also
alle drei methoden nicht die
krebsforschung hat daher ein ziel waren
sie den heiligen gral eine behandlung zu
entwickeln die alle krebszellen im
körper eines menschen erwischt auch die
noch unentdeckten und dabei gleichzeitig
keine gesunden zellen zu beschädigen die
sogenannten zielgerichteten therapien
versuchen dass die meisten von ihnen
setzen hierfür beim zellwachstum an wenn
man die teilung der tumorzellen und so
das wachsen des krebses verhindern
möchte gibt es drei möglichkeiten man
kann entweder verhindern dass das
wachstumssignale vom gehirn in der zelle
ankommt man kann die biochemischen
reaktionen stören die das signal
die zelle übersetzen oder man verhindert
dass sich der tumor neues blut gewebe
heranzüchtet dass er für seine
versorgung mit nährstoffen braucht für
bestimmte anwendungsbereiche und
krebsarten sind hier bereits
verschiedene verfahren entwickelt worden
aber den heiligen gral erreichen sie
alle noch nicht die personalisierte
medizin geht daher noch einen schritt
weiter hierfür untersucht man den
konkreten tumor des jeweiligen patienten
und versucht herauszufinden warum genau
dieser so schnell wächst hat man diesen
grund den sogenannten biomarker gefunden
kann man die therapie wählen die das am
gezielten verhindert bei vielen
tumorerkrankungen wie zum beispiel
brustkrebs darmkrebs oder lungenkrebs
sind schon zahlreiche solcher strukturen
auf den krebszellen bekannt die sich
gezielt angreifen lassen so sollen
weniger patienten eine unwirksame
behandlung bekommen die personalisierte
krebsmedizin kann den heiligen gral auch
nicht erreichen aber sie versucht
zumindest die beste verfügbare therapie
zu finden eine weitere technik aus der
viel hoffnung ruht sind sogenannte
antikörperwirkstoffkonjugat
oft auf englisch abgekürzt als
sie sollen den heiligen gral erreichen
sehr tödlich aber nur für krebszellen
die idee dahinter ist folgende man
kombiniert einen antikörper der nur an
die krebszellen an dort mit einem hoch
potenten zellgift verbunden wird beides
mit dem sogenannten linker der eine
effiziente freisetzung des giftes in der
krebszelle möglich machen soll und zwar
ohne dass die gesunden zellen
angegriffen werden so soll der krebs
ganz gezielt vernichtet werden dass das
nicht ganz einfach zu entwickeln ist
könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich denken die
probleme liegen auf allen drei ebenen
die gifte sind nicht stark genug die
linke nicht stabil genug und die
antikörper dort nicht verlässlich an die
richtigen zahlen und ohne nebenwirkungen
kommen diese medikamente meistens auch
nicht aus in allen bereichen konnten
jedoch in den letzten jahren große
fortschritte erzielt werden so dass die
ersten medikamente von diesem typ jetzt
tatsächlich auf dem markt sind man muss
jedoch sagen die ergebnisse der
zulassungsstudien muss man vorsichtig
interpretieren häufig enden diese
studien irgendwann logisch es lässt sich
also schwer voraussagen ob ein mensch
wirklich vom krebs geheilt wird den
krebs kann leider immer wieder kommen
stattdessen sprechen die studien davon
dass sich der zeitraum der tage
verlängert hat die der patient ohne eine
verschlechterung überlebt man kann also
zusammenfassen es gibt grund zur
hoffnung dass dieser medikamenten typ
die behandlung von krebs voranbringt
aber ob er wirklich das große wunder
heilmittel werden wird das wird sich
noch zeigen dieses video wurde
unterstützt durch merck ein führendes
wissenschafts und technologie
unternehmen und auch hier hat man
ziemlich spannende neue entwicklungen
zum thema antikörperwirkstoffkonjugat
vorangetrieben von denen wir euch ja
gerade schon erzählt haben auch die ldcs
von merck bestehen aus einem toxischen
wirkstoff der mit hilfe eines so
genannten link hämisch an einen
antikörper gebunden ist der antikörper
hilft hierbei dass das gift
hauptsächlich in die tumorzellen
transportiert wird und nicht in die
gesunden zellen und gewebe des körpers
gelangt und was es hier bisher an
ergebnissen gibt hört sich schon
vielversprechend an und das alles ist
nicht einfach irgendein neues medikament
sondern es steckt viel
entwicklungsarbeit darin bis jetzt hat
es knapp zwei jahrzehnte tüftelei
gebraucht bis die technologie ausgereift
war weltweit sind derzeit elf es
zugelassen zum beispiel zur behandlung
von leukämien oder brustkrebs und dann
der hälfte der aktuell auf dem markt
zugelassenen es ist merkt beteiligt dazu
kommt dass merck auch eigene herstellung
städten betreibt welche bald zu den
größten produktionsanlagen für
hochaktive wirkstoffe im einstelligen
nanogramm bereich zählen werden
gleichzeitig hat merck eigene verfahren
entwickelt die die produktion von
solchen medikamenten maßgeblich
beschleunigen so dauert es von der
herstellung bis das produkt dann auf dem
markt ist mittlerweile nur noch ein jahr
und das ist ein riesenschritt den
jüngsten innovationen und zusätzlichen
kapazitäten von merck tragen dazu bei
krebspatienten auf der ganzen welt neue
behandlungen zur verfügung zu stellen
deswegen freue mich besonders dass sie
dieses video hier unterstützt haben wenn
ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt dann
schaut gerne in die video beschreibung
also zusammenfassend kann man sagen es
ist wirklich verdammt schwierig krebs zu
behandeln kein wunder dass der eine
große durchbruch daran noch auf sich
warten lässt denn den wird es vermutlich
niemals geben wahrscheinlich wird es nur
immer wieder viele kleine durchbrüche
für die verschiedenen krebsarten geben
eine gute nachricht gibt es aber dann
doch wenn die das risiko einer
krebserkrankung verringern wollt dann
ist das rezept dazu eigentlich ziemlich
einfach gesundes essen wenig alkohol
viel sport gut eincremen und zwar mit
sonnencreme und nicht rauchen also alles
was ihr sowieso tun sollte in diesem
sinne bleibt gesund und bleibt
neugierig